obviously it's a super hot topic right
now the coronavirus yeah what what sort
of knowledge do you have about viruses
like that and kind of like what's going
on with it right now there's a couple
cases in Florida what what would you say
to people about that kind of virus and
sort of like mitigating it or you know
what is your knowledge or research if
any on stuff on viruses like this and
how to avoid them well you know I've
taken the basic course like human or you
know pathogenic microbiology biology
stuff like that so from what I know
probably you know it the people most
concerned are people immunocompromised
they're very young and they're very old
so just the standard sort of things wash
your hands stay away from people that
are sick there are many people that are
asymptomatic so we could be walking
around and be a corona virus carrier but
be asymptomatic and not be presenting so
that that in that case then it might be
good to just you know stay at home when
you can you know because you don't know
who who carry er could be so I think
that's important information our immune
systems are really a function to some
extent on our systemic and metabolic
health right so I think nutrition is
really key we want to not over nutrition
compromise the immune system
lack of sleep compromises the immune
system elevated blood glucose can
compromise the immune system so things
like intermittent fasting low carb diets
ketogenic diets can make the immune
system more vigilant to be able to deal
with these types of things you know if
they happen so we're better better off
to fight it you know in the context I
think there's some studies out there you
know showing I know there studies adrián
check the the researcher that I
mentioned showed that the immune system
becomes more vigilant with the ketogenic
diet in in regard to anti-cancer
immunity so increasing natural killer
cells and things like that
that can a better attack you know on the
cancer I believe that that's the case
for viruses and micro
- I know you mentioned earlier that when
you feel like like something coming on
like any sort of bug or something you
will automatically go into like a two
day fast or something - yeah do I
actually pay a lot more attention to my
sleep staying hydrated if I don't
completely fast I cut way back on
calories and just go into a calorie
restriction state but typically yeah oh
that's when I'll start and say okay well
time to do a short-term fast and I'll
fast for a couple days yeah yeah and I
just hardly ever get sick my wife will
get sick you know multiple times and
I'll get I feel a little something come
on and it'll never really hit our lab
just went to LA it was kind of alarming
that some of them got sick about how
rhythm and I didn't really get anything
and or I felt a little scratch in my
throat a little sniffles but nothing
ever happened so I think my immune
systems definitely a lot better now than
it was when I was not doing the Q genic
diet like you've active on knowledge
yeah like clockwork when I was you know
finals would come I would almost always
get sick at the end of November right
around that time it was like like
clockwork
and sometimes even in the spring with
finals so our immune system is really
tied to psychological stress I think can
wipe our immune system al I mean looking
back through his periods of time where I
mean physically I was doing everything
right but I was just put under a lot of
psychological stress and it just like
crushed me really yeah and just a couple
times you know that I can't remember
when certain life things just come up
you know so I think people really need
to pay attention and just kind of harder
to a little bit harder to manage right
but but be cognizant that our mental
state and behavioral effects behavioral
health probably have a the biggest
impact on our immune system so something
a lot of people don't think about stated
otherwise yeah psychological stress can
be in a very powerful immunosuppressant
and make you a vulnerable target to
something like Ramona so so our kind of
philosophy is that we were like nature
people so we I allocate a certain amount
of time each day for creative downtime
were
we get out we go in the woods we explore
things we have you know a lot of
property around us that we have you know
that are just mostly forests so we do
forestry too and spend a lot of time
just outside with our pets and unplug -
from your devices so I think it's
important you know a certain time at
night I just put my cell phone on
airplane mode and just unplug and we do
some downtime stuff like yeah yeah just
hours before bed yeah I know we sleep
better so like super important I think
for people psychological health because
they're so we're so wired and just so
attentive to our phones and that's kind
of we're very reactive sort of species
here and we do it and we don't even know
that it's compromising our health yeah
so I think it's important for people to
recognize that
[Music]
[Laughter]